[Musik]
mein heutiger gast ist eine der
schillerndsten persönlichkeiten der
deutschen politik wolfgang kubicki
stellvertretender parteivorsitzender der
fdp und vizepräsident des deutschen
bundestags herzlich willkommen bei
phoenix vielen dank sie haben ihre
autobiografie geschrieben soeben
erschienen sagen was sache ist der titel
ist mir aufgefallen sagen was sache ist
es nicht normal dass man klartext
spricht und dinge so ausdrückt wie sie
sind es sind zunächst erlebe ich ja
viele menschen die beklagen dass wir in
der politik mit sehr vielen fragen
arbeiten und nicht mehr klar wenn denn
wo die probleme liegen und welche
lösungsmöglichkeiten wir anbieten
aber es ist zweierlei es ist auch ein
buch was beschreiben will über meine
jugend wenn man eine weiterentwicklung
wie ich so geworden bin wie ich bin und
man versteht vielleicht einige meine
handlungen einige meiner äußerungen war
eine liebe zur freiheit man
unabdingbaren wählen das zu tun was ich
will so lange ich damit kann anderen
schade wenn man versteht wie ich groß
geworden bin
es ist nimmt einen relativ großen raum
in diesem buch ein dieses man muss seine
meinung frei äußern
sie beschäftigen sich auch relativ
intensiv in dem buch mit einer studie
des meinungsforschungsinstituts
allensbach ansbach hat herausgefunden
oder will herausgefunden haben dass bei
bestimmten fragen zum beispiel der
flüchtlingsfrage 71 prozent der
bevölkerung sagen ich kann nicht meine
meinung so äußern wie ich sie äußern
würde gerne stets wirklich so schlecht
um die meinungsfreiheit in deutschland
diese frage muss ich gar nicht stellen
denn ein 70 prozent der menschen glauben
das sei so läuft was falsch points in
demokratie denn unser demokratisches
gemeinwesen basiert auf dem gedanken ist
verfassungsrechtlich garantiert dass man
seine meinung solange sie im rahmen der
gesetze geäußert wird auch frei sagen
kann ohne sofort persönliche berufliche
und soziale konsequenzen tragen zu
müssen
ich will ein beispiel nennen das nicht
wirklich pikiert hat eine moderatorin
des ndr hat am wahlabend der sachsen war
gefragt ob der ministerpräsident sich
nicht eine bürgerliche koalition mit der
ard vorstellen können
nun kann man darüber streiten ob die
bürgerliche ist oder nicht ich glaube
eben nicht aber der shitstorm die sie
hat der sich anschließend erreicht hat
bis zur forderung sie dürfen nie wieder
moderieren zeigt eben dass menschen
erwarten wir haben bereits eine schere
im kopf bevor wir unsere meinung äußern
die ja nicht verifiziert werden kann man
uns ja keine tatsachenbehauptung
und wenn wir den den discos den
demokratischen diskurs über weiter
einengen die menschen das gefühl dass
man kann nur noch eine meinung haben
dann wenden sie sich ab von dem was
wichtig ist
mir ist in dem zusammenhang einsatz
aufgefallen sie sagen es gibt in
deutschland einen meinungs- mainstream
der politisch links zu verorten ist und
der tief in die mitte der gesellschaft
für unwohlsein kite und verkrampftheit
sorten kann wie wieso gibt es in
deutschland einen linken meinungs-
mainstream wo es doch in deutschland
seit vielen jahren gar keine linke
mehrheiten ergibt ja es gibt in der tat
keine linke mehrheit in den parlamenten
oder jedenfalls keine gerne rot rot
grünen mehrheit liegen teilen die
zustimmung zu den drei parteien nimmt
insgesamt weiter ab was aber nicht heißt
dass wir nicht in der lage sind die
meinungs- diskurs zu bestimmen die
klimadebatte wird in alarmismus
sozusagen geführt vor gericht stellt
sich der deutsche bundestag und sagt
landwirte sind die land vernichter
schlechthin
ich höre von von menschen die im bergbau
waren dass man sich früher gelebt hat
dafür dass sie die energieversorgung
deutschlands sichergestellt haben und
heute müssen sich ihre kinder in der
schule dafür rechtfertigen dass sie die
luft verschmutzen und das stört mich
daran dass man dass man nicht mehr
versucht zu argumentieren sondern auch
zu denunzieren das ist keine keine
singuläre erscheinung aber es ist sehr
stark bestimmt von den meinungsführern
ich sag das mal auch die in berlin mitte
sitzen und und glauben das sei bereits
der nabel der welt die diese klage dass
es in deutschland einen linken meinungs-
mainstream gebe der wird ja auch immer
von der afg hervorgebracht haben sie da
keine sorge dass wir mit dieser
argumentation in falsche gesellschaft
sind ja das ist das interessante werden
wir sagen alles was die ady sagt ist per
se schon mal schlecht und die man darf
mir das ding
da sagen dass die halle die sagt dann
bereiten wir ihnen einfällt dann müssen
sie nur alles das sagen was wir sagen
und schon müssen die dann schweigen das
ist sie kommen ja schon mit der
bürgerlichkeit sie kommen bestimmt dass
die freiheit verteidigen wollen sie
kommen wir schon damit dass sie dass sie
die die wirtschaft schützen vor zu viel
staatlichen eingriffen dass der soli
abgebaut werden muss wenn wir jetzt
jedes mal sagen würden bei die afg das
aus sagt sagen wie das nicht mehr dann
können wir abschließen
wir reden gleich noch über die afg aber
zunächst möchte ich selbstverständlich
wäre eigene partei reden über die fdp in
sachsen in brandenburg an der
fünf-prozent-hürde gescheitert
bundesweite umfragen jetzt bei 6 prozent
was ist los mit der fdp
was ist los mit dem edleren müssen mit
der fdp ist nichts los wir sind dabei
geblieben was wir sind
ich meine dass wir einen ein
kommunikationsproblem haben
das sehen wir haben daher bei der
bundestagswahl und die landtagswahl in
schleswig-holstein und
nordrhein-westfalen im jahr 2017 jeweils
mit mehr als zehn prozent abgestimmt
also an ordentlich zweistellig und
hatten dann bei der wählergruppe 60plus
auch zweistellige ergebnisse und diese
will man sagen ältere generation ist uns
irgendwann auf dem weg abhanden gekommen
denn in bayern schon bei der europawahl
in bremen und sachsen kommen wir
feststellen wir liegen bei dieser
wählergruppe unter 50 unter fünf prozent
und man kann größte wählergruppe mit der
höchsten wahlbeteiligung man kann gegen
diese wählergruppe karneval gehen also
seine aufgabe ist jetzt festzustellen
warum sind sie uns abhanden gekommen und
wie können wir sie wieder erreichen da
muss ich jetzt gleich mal ein haken das
die fdp aus der krise gekommen ist 2013
bis 2017 lag daran dass sie und lindner
ziemlich perfekt harmoniert haben das
war so eine art männerfreundschaft
würden sie das auch so sehen
ich mag den begriff männerfreundschaft
nicht aber wir haben ein sehr
vertrauensvolles freundschaftliches
verhältnis waren sogar im urlaub
mehrmals miteinander machen wir
regelmäßig noch nach wie vor zwei mal im
jahr sind wir auf verschiedenen inseln
in europa mallorca und sylt häufigkeit
yorker und sylt ist mein heimatland
schleswig-holstein mallorca liegen wir
beide in unseren jeweiligen partnern
das ist nach wie vor so wir
kommunizieren auch sehr viel miteinander
aber wir sind nicht einen fragen
deckungsgleich das wäre ökonomisch
wenden und ich bin nicht das sprachrohr
von christian linder und er ist nicht
mein sprachrohr
da dieser vertrauensvollen verhältnis
besteht nach wie vor aber
interessanterweise nützt uns das ja
nichts wie gesagt wir müssen aus diesem
teil dass wir gerade durchschreiten
wirklich möglich schnell wieder raus
kommen wir haben thüringen war vor uns
ja und die wahl in hamburg frühjahr
nächsten jahres vor uns und wir wollen
das ist unser gemeinsames ziel die fdp
im deutschen bundestag wieder
zweistellig halte ich habe einen grund
warum mich das mit der
männerfreundschaft jetzt angesprochen
hat weil sie haben das jetzt so
ausführlich zitiert mit den über
60-jährigen diesel verloren haben sie
haben ja auch gesagt also alles bunt und
knallig bei der fdp das hat man so als
versteckte kritik an der strategie von
von lindner verstanden und er hat jetzt
dann auch gleich zurück getwittert wenn
er gut ist wenn wolfgang wieder stärker
mit macht also das heißt doch wohl
er hätte sich vielleicht vorher ein
bisschen mehr für die fdp anstrengen
sollen also so richtig freundlich ist
das zumindest nicht identifizieren er so
nicht also im prinzip hat er dann jetzt
zum ausdruck gebracht dass er wünscht er
hat ja auch in der bundespressekonferenz
und will nach den wahlen festgestellt
hat uns über 60 jahren angekommen sind
und ich habe dass er als als schmonzette
verstanden dann sollte diese du bist
genau der typ den wir brauchen und über
60 jahren wieder bekommen ist eine
kleine frechheit aber jedenfalls war es
irgendwie schmonzette ok werden wird
trotzdem mal über die weiter über diese
krise da bleibt man dann mal dran ich
ich würde behaupten die themen für die
fdp die liegen doch auf der straße
er fordert ein kevin kühnert die
vergesellschaftung von bmw der berliner
senat arbeitet daran die mieten
staatlich festzulegen
die grünen wollen die suvs verbieten wo
bleibt da der fdp war ein echter nichts
ja diese frage kann ich jetzt auch nicht
beantworten weil ich jeden tag nicht nur
höhere und sondern auch lese was die fdp
dazu sagt und wie sie funktioniert in
dem sinne wie man das von freien
demokraten auch erwarten können
möglicherweise auch das video ist ein
kommunikationsproblem ist wir müssen
mein empfinden weniger technokratisch
formulieren sondern auch mal wirklich
auf die tonne hauen nicht also ich würde
sagen wenn der berliner senat anmieten
deckel schöne geschichte die ich auch an
kraft werden wenn ein berliner
bezirksbürgermeister erklärt dass seine
seiner stadtparks gern das dealen
zulassen würde wissen wir dass ein
krimineller muss man einfach einsparen
denn es ist die anstiftung zu einer
straftat oder zumindest die beteiligung
strafe also man muss vielleicht auch mal
in dem konzert der vielen öffentlichen
erklärungen so pointiert formulieren
dass auch sie nicht daran vorbeikommen
würden das zu transportieren also worauf
karibik kubicki ist ja da glaube ich das
richtige und diese linie vorzugehen
es gibt allerdings auch leute die sagen
es liegt einfach daran dass die fdp
keinen fuß mehr auf den boden kriegt
weil sie auf sehr sehr unglückliche art
und weise aus den sondierungsgesprächen
ausgestiegen sind er zunächst einmal
kriegen wert noch füße auf den boden
wenn man meinungsumfrage überhaupt
trauen sollte dann muss man sich
angucken wie sie in schleswig holstein
aus nordrhein-westfalen in baden
württemberg da sind die entweder
zweistellig oder nahe der
zweistelligkeit das hat sich nicht
geändert
unsere ostdeutschen bundesländer sind
für die freien demokraten immer schon
sehr schweres tragen
lesen wir hatten uns natürlich erhofft
wir kommen hinein aber wenn sie
landesverbände haben die zu zwei
dritteln die landesfläche gar nicht
bespielen können weil sie zu wenig
mitglieder haben wenn sie eine struktur
haben die nicht gerade wohl nicht gerade
ein humus hat aus mittelständlern und
selbst in der gewachsen ist auch in
einer nennenswerten größenordnung dann
ist das alles wirklich ein problem und
das kann man auch nicht nicht
beschönigen ich sage immer wieder gucken
wir uns thüringen kann gucken wir uns
haben wir ja da wird man feststellen die
fdp ist da und die wird auch da bleiben
aber wir werden aufpassen müssen dass
wir nicht nur wahrgenommen werden als
partei der unter 24-jährigen der juden
sondern wir müssen da genommen werden
auch die partei die sich für die belange
der 45 bis zu 70 jährigen einsetzt und
da sind andere kriterien anzulegen als
das gegenwärtig der fall ist ich dachte
auch an einem beispiel die man wo mir
aufgefallen ist wir haben in bayern
geworben mit einem plakat das neue
bayern habe ich schon nicht gewusst was
ich damit anfangen soll ich habe da mal
die namen gefragt was heißt das neue
bayern die muss dann beispiele bringen
was ist dann neu an bayern freuen ist
das kein guter slogan immer weiß dass 90
prozent der bayern mit ihrem bayern
zufrieden sind dann muss man schon
erklären was besser und schöner werden
wird und das ist für mich wie gesagt ein
kommunikations merkel wir müssen bilder
produzieren müssen beispiele liefern
auch in der klimafrage warum fahren wir
nicht mal gemeinsam ist mache ich jetzt
auch nach schlesien nach high der nach
tellingstedt und ist eine ein referat in
berlin ist beginnt wasserstoff zu
produzieren mit hilfe des windstroms den
wenn ich ableiten können aus schleswig
holstein und daraus synthetisches
kerosin zu machen das heißt eine
klimaneutrale in treibstoff wird zu
entwickeln
dann müssen wir uns mal die frage von
flugreisen nicht mehr halten also an
solchen kleinen praktischen beispielen
kann man zeigen dass mit technik mit
innovationen mal probleme bewältigen
kann und nicht nur mit verbot und und
verzicht trotzdem gerne noch mal wissen
was in dieser nacht der letzten nacht
der jamaica sondierungen passiert ist
warum ist das so auseinander geflogen
sie können mir glauben ich komme ja aus
einer funktionierenden markt koalition
in schleswig-holstein wir haben
erfolgreich verhandelt wir hatten einen
guten koalitionsvertrag sie funktioniert
bis heute wirklich hervorragend was
niemand für möglich gehalten hat wir
haben da nicht viereinhalb wochen
gesessen um mit dem ziel hier stehen auf
und gehen daraus aber wenn sie nach
viereinhalb wochen feststellen dass sie
sich ganz kleinen kreis gedreht dass sie
zu keinen punkt
kommen wo wir vertreten könnten das
lohnt sich jetzt in gespräche
einzutreten für eine koalition
dann ist auch irgendwann mal schicht im
schacht ist einfach schluss letzte nacht
war so dass das nachmittag am sonntag
damit dass die kanzlerin
christian lindner gefragt hat wie seine
achte runde herr linder was brauchen sie
denn jetzt und da christian lindner
neuen punkte aufgezählt und dann die
kanzlei ungelogen immer gesagt darüber
können wir reden das können wir machen
das kriegen wir auf die reihe darüber
verhandeln
aber dann sind wir ja am späten
nachmittag völlig überrascht weil wir
wieder vier wochen nicht zurande kann
völlig überrascht nach unten gegangen
sondern unserer delegation haben gesagt
wenn das jetzt umgesetzt wird es
vorgetragen dann können wir
koalitionsverhandlungen fielen alle
waren glücklich zufrieden also richtig
christa auch gesagt dann noch das ist
das ist typisch merkel alles bis zum
schluss aufheben und dann in der langen
nacht der langen messer hat den knoten
durchzuschlagen und mit der information
und sind hier damals nikolai b johannes
vogel in fernsehsendungen gegangen und
haben ihnen fernsehsendungen erklärt es
wird was dann sind wir wieder nach oben
gegangen zum abstieg ist besprechung
kommen hoch und dann geht es los geht
leider nicht können wir nicht machen
kriege ich ärgerlich bin eben mit dem
minister versenken herger und er war
völlig neue punkten wieder alles auf
null
und da sagen sie auch irgendwann sie
sind einfach zu alt um sich auf den arm
nehmen zu lassen
haben sie den eindruck gewonnen dass
angela merkel die jamaica gespräche
absichtlich hat scheitern lassen oder
zumindest gar keinen erfolg wollte also
robert habeck hat ja jetzt zu recht auch
öffentlich erklärt die ersten 14 tagen
hat die kanzlerin nur die rednerliste
gefühlt nicht einen einzigen eigenen
beitrag leistet dann ist es so fragen
sie mal daniel günther oder robert
habeck wie wir angefangen haben
koalitionsverhandlungen gespräche zu
fühlen kannst als mal angefangen mit der
wir schreiben erst mal alles auf was uns
trennt mal zunächst zu gucken wo haben
wir gemeinsamkeiten weil wenn sie das
gelöst haben ist es entkrampfte um
weiter voran zu gehen
und wer während der viereinhalb wochen
weil wir sehr sehr viel geredet haben
teilweise bis zu 14 stunden am tag haben
sie dann seht ihr in den halbschlaf sie
sind also nicht mehr voll fit und
deshalb können sich auch nicht
analysieren diese in dieser phase wobei
die kanzlerin ich weiß nicht wie sie das
macht dann wenn wir bis 2 uhr nachts
seien gesessen dann wenn ich morgens um
sieben schon wieder fit
ich kenne das ja auch von früher aber
war schon also körperlich schon eine
beachtliche leistung nachhinein ist mir
klargeworden die kanzlerin wollte diese
konstellation ist sie wollte die große
koalition fortsetzen sie hat am
wahlabend nicht verstanden warum die
sozialdemokraten sagen wir gehen raus
hat sie auch öffentlich erkläre ich
verstehe das gar nicht wie eine
gemeinsame mehrheit und ihrer auch klar
wenn michael scheitert kommen die
sozialdemokraten wieder mindestens den
staatspolitischer verantwortung und die
hat jetzt wieder das was sie wollte sich
regiert mit leuten zusammen die sie
kennt sie regiert mit strukturen
zusammen die sie kennt sie muss ich hin
musste sich nicht nur einstellen und sie
hat eben dazu beigetragen dass der weg
der sozialdemokratie auch die
einstelligkeit fortgesetzt worden
und ist es jetzt vorbei bis jamaika oder
kann das wiederkommen in der phase nach
merkel ja zunächst einmal glaube ich das
ist wirklich ein modell ist auch für
deutschland was dazu beitragen kann
konflikte in der gesellschaft zu
befrieden
ich sehe das in schleswig-holstein alle
fühlen sich irgendwo vertreten bei der
ansprechpartner haben
und alle können mit den kompromissen die
wir finden leben weil sie mitbekommen
haben dass darüber die geräte diskutiert
werden dass man sich wirklich bemüht
alle argumente aufzunehmen wir werden
wahrscheinlich erleben dass auch nach
der nächsten bundestagswahl ist für eine
zweier konstellation nicht reichen wird
und dass wir drei parteien brauchen die
regieren müssen die sozialdemokraten
feiern aus mit der ard weg einer gott
sei dank
die linken haben sich mittlerweile auch
fast halbiert gegenüber ihren früheren
zahlen also ist wird wenn es drei
parteien braucht schon michael
hinauslaufen und ich kann ihnen sicher
sagen jetzt nach zwei jahren des
gemeinsamen wirkens hier im deutschen
bundestag es hat sich viel verändert im
klima zwischen den parteien zwischen den
fraktionen
es ist zwischen personen auf vertrauen
gewachsen beim nächsten da glaube ich
kriege das hin
wir reden noch mal über die afg sie
müssen wir an ganz prominenter stelle
nämlich als vizepräsident des deutschen
bundestages festlegen was der richtige
umgang mit der afg ist nämlich im plenum
des deutschen bundestages haben sie
irgendwie so ein rezept wie umgehen mit
der alte also ich kann und darf mich
festlegen wie man mit der afg umgeht ich
habe dann müssen aber für sich
entscheiden machen die geschäftsordnung
anzuwenden und zu beachten das mache ich
sehr strikt und zwar gegenüber allen
also nicht nur geber der afg sondern
auch gegenüber
auch sozialdemokraten und grüne hat von
mir schon ordnungsrufe bekommen für
äußerungen in richtung af.de die einfach
die grenzen des anständigen verletzt
persönlich glaube ich außerhalb meiner
funktion als vize präsident wäre es
geschickter die iaaf die manchmal ins
leere laufen zu lassen oder sie auf den
arm zu nehmen statt immer mit dieser
moralische überheblichkeit zu kommen ihr
seid rechtspopulisten über neonazis und
das was ihr sagt müssen wir deshalb gar
nicht beachten wir sehen ja in schleswig
holstein sind wie mit ihnen umgegangen
dass man nicht reagiert etwas stehen
lässt sich ja auf die lebt von der
reaktion sie leben nicht von dem was sie
tut sie hat sich auf die opferrolle
eingestellt da ist ja muss beklagen dass
die altparteien von denen sie dass das
system sie nicht will das ist die
wiederholung des wahlkampfs stilvollen
von jump in usa
ich muss gegen dieses ist durch und
durch versiffte establishment in
washington an kämpfen wählt mich dann
rolle ich dann wieder auf dass die
attitüde derart die auch und wir müssen
aufpassen dass wir nicht dauernd genau
das machen was sie von uns erwarten und
was sie was sie auch wie um diese rolle
spielen zu können also teile diese
opferrolle ist es ja dass die anderen
parteien der afd den vize präsidenten
des deutschen bundestages der der fdp
der elfte eigentlich zusteht verweigert
ist es richtig jetzt zunächst einmal hat
die afg wie alle fraktionen des
deutschen bundestages das recht einen
vize präsidenten vorzuschlagen
sie hat aber kein benennungsrecht das
heißt der hat vorgeschlagen oder die
vorgeschlagen kandidatin muss immer noch
gewählt werden wenn die mehrheit des
hauses diesen kandidaten ich wählt gab
es übrigens bei lothar bisky auch schon
mal bei den linken ist eine neue
geschichte
dann ist es einfach so dass muss man in
demokratie aushalten ich habe früher der
p4 plädiert bis vor wenigen monaten soll
ich das man sagen dass dafür plädiert
diesem demokratischen grundgedanken zu
folgen sie haben anspruch darauf also
muss man den anspruch erfüllen wir haben
eine afd kann die darin auch mal gewählt
das war natürlich habe ich gewählt
definitiv und habe auf meiner fraktion
empfehlen empfohlen das zu tun unter
anderem das ja auch getan
aber mittlerweile bin ich davon weg und
zwar deshalb weil das auftreten von af
die abgeordneten und funktionären gegen
meinen grundverständnis verstöße dass
ich habe wir haben artikel 1 des
grundgesetzes ist der lautet die würde
des menschen ist unantastbar sie zu
achten und zu schützen ist aufgabe aller
staatlichen gewalt und ich habe viele
debattenbeiträge viele verhaltensweisen
von hd kollegen kollegen erlebt die
genau diese menschenwürde gegen bei
menschen mit muslimischem glauben oder
andere hautfarbe schlichten ergreift mit
füßen treten und ich möchte nicht dass
unser parlament das parlament dem ich
angehöre von einem repräsentanten
vertreten würden nach außen gegenüber
dritten auch der diese grundsätze aus
artikel 1 nicht beherzigt wenn sie da
jetzt sagen da ist eine partei und deren
vertreter verstoßen ganz offen gegen den
zentralen paragrafen unseres
grundgesetzes die würde des menschen ist
unantastbar
gibt es da nicht eigentlich nur einen
weg nämlich vors verfassungsgericht zu
gehen und zu sagen die partei muss
verboten werden
abgesehen davon dass das ja nur von
landesregierung beantragt werden kann
oder von der bundesregierung oder im
deutschen bundestag ist
verfassungsfeindlich noch nicht
verfassungswidrig des
bundesverfassungsgerichts setzt sehr
sehr strenge grenzen bei der frage des
verbots an der partei oder von
organisationen oder einzelpersonen beim
npd verfahren haben ist gerade
festgestellt dass ein antrag
abgeschmettert worden ist mit der
begründung dieser nicht mehr starken
noch überhaupt ein umsturz herbeiführen
zu können es muss eine aktive aggressive
haltung gegenüber im grundgesetz geben
das kann ich bei der afg nicht
feststellen
sie ist für mich in teilen wirklich
asmus feindlichkeit den geist der
verfassung gar nicht verstanden aber ich
würde was im deutschen bundestag angeht
länder kenne ich nicht so sehr genau
nicht davon ausgehen dass diese dass die
opposition hfd dem deutschen bundestag
verfassungswidrig ist noch mal ein zitat
von ihnen dass ich ganz interessant wenn
unsere politik der radikalen ausgrenzung
hat nicht geholfen im gegenteil sie hat
er geschadet also ich interpretiere das
hat auch wieder so das was letztendlich
geschieht im bundestag nicht wahr eines
vize-präsidenten oder in dieser
radikalen abgrenzung wir machen mit
denen nichts gemeinsam was immer die
sagen wir stimmen nicht zu
die bringt am ende gab
ja nicht diese strategie sondern die
strategie der moralische überheblichkeit
dass man sagt wir sind die besseren
menschen oder die demokraten seit eh und
je sagt die schlechteren menschen weil
die rechtspopulisten oder rechtsradikale
seit ich glaube dass die intellektuell
auseinandersetzungen viel durchgreifen
der wäre weil die menschen das gefühl
hätten wir grenzen nicht menschen aus
sondern wir beschäftigen uns mit dem was
sie sagen und weisen das zurück ich habe
weiche keine diskussion mit einem lauf
deakes wieder mit bauland noch sonstwie
weil demokraten grundsätzlich nicht
weichen weil immer noch glaube dass
meine argumente die besseren sind über
diesen argumenten oder scheinargumente
die afg das soll jetzt das schlusswort
gewesen sein nicht in dieser sendung
aber in der diskussion der aktuellen
politik weil wir ja auch noch ein
bisschen mehr erfahren worden über ihr
bewegtes leben
wir haben jetzt einige fotos vorbereitet
67 jahre wolfgang kubicki im
schnelldurchlauf jetzt hoffe ich dass es
auch eine kamera gibt
da können wir das sehen das sind sie
nicht mit ihrer mutter sondern ihre
tante ist das ist meine tante tante mia
die schwester meiner mutter die ich
gehasst habe wie die pest weil sie mich
darunter ziehen würde
umso schlimmer dass wir ihnen jetzt
ausgerechnet dieses foto angefressen der
lange er das bin ich weiß gar nicht weil
ich weil ich konnte wahrscheinlich
gerade erst laufen in der straße ich bin
hier in der kleinen straße in lehndorf
in braunschweig geboren wurden in der
kleinen straße die wirklich klein ist
wenn sie heute sieht früher war das für
mich riesig
bild von der schule sie waren glaube ich
eine eher komplizierte schüler
ich war nicht ganz einfach auch schüler
also das ist jeweils das foto nach der
einschulung und ich war deshalb ganz
einfach bei dem er keine regeln gehalten
haben obwohl wir genau neben der schule
wohnte in einem halbjahr 52 mal zu spät
gekommen da steht bei mir jetzt sollte
man drin ich würde auch keine disziplin
los was wahrscheinlich auch stimmte
fußball bilder aus der zeit als
breiterer braunschweig der einzige er
nicht kniet dass wir nicht unten in der
mitte zweites leben dann haben wir als
nächstes das tanzstunde glaube es war
der abschluss bei der tanzstunde und ich
habe festgestellt dass ich doch eine
sehr hübsche partnerin damals hatte
schade dass nicht mehr weiß wer es war
und
und sie wohnt das war umgeht war nach
meiner vereinigung ist als anwalt in der
kanzlei die werden ich fand es so toll
mal mit robe fotografiert zu gern das
bild meiner mutter geschickt hat sich
darüber sehr gefreut wir sind immer
anwalt geblieben die ganze karriere
durch also ich bin volkswirt von haus
aus habt jetzt zuvor bevor ich anwalt
wurde habe ich in einem stolper von
unternehmensberatungs büro gearbeitet
haben jura studiert mit anwalt geworden
seit die kita ist das mit irgendwelchem
an
ich glaube es ist kurz vor der
jahrtausendwende wie bei einem wahlkampf
als wir in pinneberg waren sie dann
gemeinsam gegessen oder eine wirkliche
freundschaft zwischen ihnen und
möllemann mit mit tragischem ende ja
also ein sehr intensiv
freundschaftliches verhältnis
freundschaft mehr wir hatten relativ
wenige soziale berührungspunkte also
wenn sie nicht in der gleichen stadt
leben und ich ihnen zweiten abend man
mit jemandem einen trinken gehen könnten
aber es war ein sehr festes tolles
verhältnis und ganz am ende haben wir
jetzt noch ein foto gesehen mit ihren
beiden töchtern aus
unter meinem hund gehört aus meiner zwei
zwillingstöchter oftmals w
ich habe einen sehr interessanten
artikel im spiegel gelesen sehr wohl
wollen das porträt über sie dann wären
sie so beschrieben als ein politiker der
eigentlich aus der zeit gefallen ist
denn es so eigentlich gar nicht mehr
geben kann einer aus einer zeit wo die
männer noch männer seien dürften unseres
gefällt ihnen so eine beschreibung die
sie bei mir relativ egal also der titel
lautete der letzte seiner art und hält
man gehe mittlerweile sehr schätze habe
ich ein jahr begleitet ich habe schon
gesagt wir können artikel doch gleich
träumen ich weiß genau was das sein soll
sondern ein akku blick gehe ich wie sie
wirklich beobachten und da stellt er
innerhalb dieses jahres fest dass ich
wirklich so bin wie ich bin dass kanada
die tüte ist er beschreibt ja auch eine
szene ich mit einem abgeordneten in den
usa umgeht und schreibt dann auch eher
darunter vielleicht ist das die bessere
art mit derartigen als das was wir
machen da habe ich auch niemand auf den
arm genommen herrn müller der nach
mexiko wollen und ich mir gesagt herr
müller nicht in mexiko werden viele
leute erschossen und er hat dann sich
dank dafür dass ich ihn vor diesen
sicherheitsrisiko warne ich habe nur
gesagt es kann ja sein dass sie trifft
und man muss mit dem leben die menschen
einen einschätzen also und deshalb habe
ich das buch geschrieben damit leute
sich selbst einen eindruck darüber
verschaffen können wie ist der kerl
wirklich und wie soll da hingekommen es
gibt so viele szenen in meinem leben
über die man auch lachen und schmunzeln
kann
das findet sie auch in dem buch wieder
und man verstehe ich sie jetzt ich habe
ich habe die leute die das buch in die
menschen jetzt buch gelesen haben und
haben sich an der teilweise angerufen
hat jetzt verstehen wir sie viel besser
jacobi also meine frau und ich beispiele
sind seit 30 jahren zusammen und jeder
tag ist nicht derselbe ist anders wir
haben keine konkrete planung ist kommen
überraschungen
es gibt beim hermann ott bilder von
ihnen und ihrer frau geben das gefühl es
geht immer bei uns darum wer hat das
sagen meine frau würde sagen
selbstverständlich du aber in wahrheit
geht jeden tag mehr sagen sie ist auch
strafverteidigerin was das eben sehr
interessant macht weil wir beide mit
sprache sehr gut umgehen können und
diese szene in meinem leben habe ich
hatte mir haben eine wirklich richtigen
streit um eine frau an gutem brand die
tür zugeknallt ist losglück team
gefahren und ich habe gedacht diesmal
kriegst du nicht einen diesmal gibt es
keine blümchen als entschuldung des
berufs auch nicht an dass das tust du
jetzt mal durch so das hat meine frau
wahrscheinlich gemerkt ich weiß nicht
ich kriegte am nachmittag eine sms von
ihr
ich nehme die entschuldigung an neulich
zurückgeschrieben welche entschuldigung
hat sie geschrieben was mir doch gerade
einen ring geschenkt ich war bei bulgari
und haben die gesagt jemand hat einen
ring für sie bestellt und das war das
fand ich so geladen wo es gut die wut
weil in der sekunde weg ich hätte von
meiner frau auf die knie gehen können
weil das man so brillant eine wirklich
beklemmende situation auflösen kann
unglaublich mein heiratsantrag auch so
eine geschichte ich habe bei uns im dorf
an in deinem plakatiert enge liebe
meines lebens willst du meine frau
werden und meine frau geht morgens immer
mit dem hund als erste raus gegeben ihm
spazieren und auch am ostersonntagmorgen
ich habe das hier außer samstag geht's
hier aus und kommt wieder und ich denke
wenn die tür aufgeht fällt im heiz und
sagt ja möchte ich gerne hin und wie man
sich das so vorstellt und da kommt sie
rein und nichts nichts der gewissenlos
sondern telefonie gekriegt mir die
ersten anrufe und dann haben nachbarn
und freunde angerufen meiner frau
kontrolliert an hat sie gesagt wie
und dann sind da manchmal heiratsantrag
gemacht und meine frau wut der bank
gesagt alle anderen wissen dass nur ich
nicht ich sage du bist hier dann 20
plakaten vorbei gelaufen was auch nicht
darauf geachtet
nehmen wir das vergaß dass wir am ende
gehen gegenüber an
dann hat sich das aufgelöste war
zunächst nicht fröhlich sondern wütend
dass andere vor ihr wussten dass sie
ihren heiratsantrag
ich habe noch was gefunden annette muss
man sagen ist ihre dritte frau aber
inzwischen sind fast 30 jahre zusammen
also das zitat laute dort annette hatte
es öffentlich als ihre aufgabe
bezeichnet mich vor größenwahn und
überheblichkeit zu schützen ja wieder
anfällig da sagt sie auch öffentlich sie
regelmäßig sagte zu mir nicht ein genie
küste im wahnsinn die füße und er sagt
ja auch einmal wieder weil ich ja sehr
plötzlich auf formuliere gelegentlich
passt auf dass das nicht als arrogant
rüberkommt und machen dich nicht so
wichtig nehme ich mal ein bisschen
zurück vielleicht und das ist gut wenn
man jemanden hatte die rein auf diese
art und weise auch geredet wenn sie
sonst sehr schnell dabei von sich selbst
überzeugt in diesem rausch dass er
bewusst sein die dinge zu tun oder
aussagen zu tätigen die am hinterher
leidtun
sie hat auch gesagt ich habe in weicher
und menschlicher gemacht
lassen sie das überhaupt mit sich machen
so dass jemand sie da um ruby hatte
asiate hat und daran gearbeitet weil sie
mehr sagt du bist ein emotionsloser
klotz und sie hat es tatsächlich
geschafft dann mehrere jahre gedauert
dass sie auch wirklich mal 1 stpo
kommentar in die hand genommen haben
angeschmissen da aber das hat sie
richtig gefreut hat sich richtig gefreut
dass ihr gelungen sei mich emotional so
aufzuführen was mir sonst nicht liegt
mich dann auch mal gehen zu lassen und
mittlerweile ist das auch so dass sie
durch ständiges training einfach auch
lernen miteinander besser umzugehen und
ich bin wirklich weicher geworden meine
ganzen mitarbeiter die lange bei mir
sind sagen dass ich bin nachsichtige
geworden weil weicher geworden und ich
sage das weil wir das ist die weisheit
ist ein und und das mit macho image das
sie entweder pflegen oder sie sind halt
einfach so also solche bemerkungen die
koalitionsverhandlungen gehen solange
meine frau sollen wir ein paar neue
bringen das sind ja auch immer so dass
das war nicht ganz geheuer ist
es war donnerstag eigentlich sollte die
veranstaltung donnerstag zu ende sein
also daten vom zeitplan her und das war
die nacht der langen messer und
donnerstagmorgen 4 uhr hab ich gesagt
ich habe jetzt genug ich gehe jetzt nach
hause und kommen nicht wieder da hat
christian gesagt geht nicht wenn du
nicht wieder kommen sind die verhandlung
zu ende die kanzlerin hat gesagt habe
ich sie haben doch selbst bei spiegel
gesagt auf ein oder zwei tage mehr oder
weniger konstant gehörten sonntag weiter
waren so und dann nicht nach hause
gefahren habe die dusche und musste ins
morgenmagazin und stehe vor meinem
schrank und sehe umhüllung sehe das in
meinem schrank nur noch ein weiß ist
also das weiße hemd ist er sich anziehen
will
von gleicher völlig die zeit völlig
verloren habe nicht daran gedacht dass
freitag ist also dem geschäft gehen
können habe ich zum schluss auch die
frage was eigentlich größtes problem
habe ich dann gesagt dass ich keine
weißen hemden er habe und dann war diese
länder die redaktion aus köln gesagt
hätte wir würden ihn gerne helfen wir
herr altmaier hat mir angeboten dass ich
einen sohn bekommen kann habe ich
zurückgeschrieben ich brauchte weißes
hemd und ein zwei mann zelt und robert
habeck mir geschrieben
ich kenne würde ja gerne aushelfen aber
ich hab nur schwarze hemden mit und so
weiter und der tagesspiegel hat bei
meiner frau angerufen die das gar nicht
mitbekommen hatte und hat gefragt waren
sie jetzt nach berlin und bringen sie
ihrem mann weiße hemden hat sie gesagt
dass wir schon allein regeln können ich
war nicht seinetwegen 600 berlin meinem
büro hat ja schon alles organisiert aber
das war so eine szene nicht die ist
durch getragen jetzt meiner frau viel
ruhm eingebracht sie wir sind erschienen
in der neuen zürcher zeitung in den
salzburger nachrichten
als meine frau die einen sagen denn ich
bin ja nicht das haus weibchen ist
wolfgang kubicki sondern einem
einzelsitz touch oder nicht ja wenn ich
sage ich esse gerne steak und ich liebe
es mit frauen zu flirten und ich bin
immer sehr höflich lieber auf guten
beinen dann im frühjahr motorrad
gefallen ist mir ist ja verboten worden
den des hohen alters von meinem büro
sozusagen
ich liebe auch etwas sind die intensive
auseinandersetzung ja ich bin auch ein
robuster typ wenn das leute als macho
empfinden dann ist das eben so ist mir
auch wurscht
das war phoenix persönlich heute mit
wolfgang kubicki hat vielen dank
[Musik]